[Music]
let's go to paul in riverside california
hey paul how are you
hi
hi george hey what's going on
so right now i'm an escrow on the house
um
purchase price is 5.85
i sold my house so i have to be out of
here
tomorrow over moving out
and uh we're gonna get to this other
house next week
so we're gonna stay at my mother's wall
mother-in-law for a week
uh but it turns out this house is uh
a little bit more than what we were
hoping to pay
so they quoted us
around 2 600 a month for our 30-year
mortgage
and it came back that there's some
special taxes on the house
and some mallory and stuff so payments
the new payments 2900 a month what's
your take home
uh
between 80 and 90.
80 90 000 a year
yeah is what you take home and that and
that quote you said is based on a
30-year mortgage
yeah 30-year mortgage
well uh
you said you're in escrow right
actually sorry
what'd you say
the 80-90 that's uh my gross income
so your take home is a lot less than
that then
yeah
we're probably talking 60 take home
you're talking about five grand a month
is what ends up in your bank account
uh i think about 500 uh a month 5 500 a
month and this mortgage payment on a 30
year
is that i mean it's taking up 50 of your
income on a 30-year mortgage you guys
are going to be drowning in this thing
this is this is a
no-paw what can you do instead
how do you get out of this thing
i'm not sure it's uh uh i was thinking
we stayed with my mother-in-law that she
has a
two-bedroom apartment and there's
me my wife and my three kids
but even at 2600 this thing was was way
out of your budget
without the special taxes
yeah we're looking for 25 of take-home
pay
on a 15-year fixed rate so this is way
way way out
i think you guys are not ready to
get a house right now i mean it sounds
like unless you can stay at the
mother-in-law's for a while until you
find something that you can afford do
you guys have any other debt
uh i got about 2 500 and credit cards
that i can pay that off yeah
yeah uh so
do you have any savings yeah
well i made money on the on my house
that i just sold
yes okay how much did you make on that
about 170.
okay so where is that money going was
that going as a down payment on this new
one
so about 130 was going to the
donkey and the other 40
um
savings
okay for like your fully funded
emergency fund
yeah paul i think we got to slow down
here um and wait until this thing makes
sense for our budget and for our life
because i can feel the anxiety already
of what this is going to do to you guys
and so i think you need to back out of
this thing take a pause rent stay with
family do what you need to do until
number one you get all this debt cleaned
up all the consumer debt we have a fully
funded emergency fund and then whatever
money is left over that's going to
become our down payment we're going to
keep building that up and i want you to
do a 15-year fixed rate with a payment
that's no more than a quarter of your
take-home pay and i want you to have a
good solid down payment of 10 to 20 or
more that's what's going to give you
guys some peace well it sounds like
you're going to have that with the the
money you just made on this house with
the savings and the um being able to pay
off the debt like you said i i think
this starts with a conversation with
your mother-in-law
and just seeing what does this time
frame look like and do you guys rent for
a little while because you don't want to
rush a home pers purchase it's not this
house we know that you can't afford this
house which is fine
but so that you don't rush and make a
desperate decision which desperate
decisions are almost always bad
decisions i would suggest you guys
staying with the in-laws maybe
short-term very short-term finding
something to rent until you can find the
right house that you can afford under
the parameters that george just gave you
15-year fixed rate and and that so
whatever your payment is is going to be
less than 25 of your take-home pay after
you've put that down payment you just
said and you keep your fully funded
emergency fund with your 2500 of debt
paid off so you've got the ability to do
that we just still don't want to rush
into a home purchase just because you
can and it's definitely not this house
yeah and paul i don't want to crush your
dreams here so i want you to do is keep
dreaming but work towards that dream and
you can jump onto our mortgage
calculator ramseysolutions.com
and starts to play around with the
numbers and see hey what would it take
for us to do this the right way so
that's a blessing and not a curse so
that we're not house poor so that we're
not pouring all of our income into this
house that is probably going to have
more repairs and more problems and more
taxes and all of these things are going
to crunch your budget even further
because remember we have other goals we
need to save for college save for
retirement pay off the house early do
all kinds of things so that we can
retire with dignity so do it the right
way don't put yourself in this position
yeah paul i think the and i know you
said the mother-in-law's place is is
small but i would just encourage you to
start working now today on finding
somewhere to rent somewhere that you can
afford
with your kids with your family in the
interim until you find the right house
and i think you will and you'll be
happier with where you end up because
you didn't rush it and you certainly
didn't get yourself into a situation
with the house that you can't afford
that is just going to absolutely um eat
up everything they have where you can't
make any decisions you have no margin so
yeah have a conversation with in-laws
find a place to rent and then when
you're ready you will find the right
house and um and you'll be really glad
you waited
when people rush george
it always almost always messes things up
don't rush dave ramsey says this all the
time it's the tortoise and the hare we
want to be the tortoise slow and steady
wins the race every single time